okay why don't we uh go ahead and get
started good morning y'all great to see
everybody um so today we are very lucky
to have prad Hara from the Tata
Institute of fundamental research uh to
tell us about multiplicity codes so this
I think can be viewed as maybe a a
followup to the two lectures that that I
gave yesterday which were sort of like
all over the place of algebraic codes
and and now prelot is going to go a
little bit deeper into one particular
type of algebraic code which I didn't
get a chance to talk about it all multip
multiplicity codes um and unfortunately
due to Visa reasons prad is not able to
join us in person but hopefully he'll be
here later um yeah so thanks so much for
coming pad thanks so much for uh I guess
staying up late and uh take it
away can you all hear me is that good
the voice good okay thanks Mary let's
get started so uh good morning to all of
you you or a good night from Bombay it's
unfortunately I couldn't I'm I'm not
there right now due to some
administrative processing on my Visa
front I hope to be there in a few weeks
let's see how it proceeds anyway so what
I will be talking today is I'm going to
go a deep dive into multiplicity codes
these are a special family of algebraic
codes from the S family that Mary talked
about
yesterday it's my second favorite family
of codes first favorite of course being
read Solomon and read M codes
and multiplicity codes it's usually
described as higher derivative variance
of read Solomon or read M quotes and
basically it's sort of said that at
every the usual re Solomon code is a set
of evaluations of a polinomial here you
not only give the evaluations but also
several higher derivative
information so that's the usual way
defined I'll take a slightly more
gradual non-standard defining these
codes so what we'll do in this talk the
talk will be structured one we'll spend
a fair amount of time motivating and
defining multiplicity Goods both the uni
both the univariate version the
multivariate version then we look at one
one of the one nice applications of the
unate multiplicity codes which gives
rise to list decodable codes all the way
up to capacity many talk about a family
of such codes the folder read Solomon
codes and other family which for which
we know we can list decode
algorithmically up to capacity are the
univariate multiplicity codes we will
then see the multivariate multiplicity
codes particular while trying to analyze
the multiv multiplicity codes we'll also
see the multiplicity schatzle LMA and
then see an application of them towards
High rate locally decodable
codes and at the very end I will talk
about various open questions is related
to multiplicity codes by the way this
strange giving a remote talk on this
topic I would like to do this would I
like to do this on board so feel free
stop me I I have a lot of material you
can see the number of slides it's 107
slides so hopefully it's not that long I
can stop at any point of time so please
stop me and ask questions if you have
any let's make it as interactive as
possible as can be done in a remote talk
okay so let's get started so we're going
to even before we to motivate
multiplicity codes let's recall the
polinomial evaluation codes in
particular let's recall these two
families of codes which we saw which we
Mary possibly talked about in ester's
lecture is lectures read Solomon codes
and read M codes read Solomon codes are
the evaluations of univariate polinomial
read M codes are evaluations of
multivariate polinomial to be a little
more precise PR Solomon codes are of the
following type there's some underlying
field a finite field field there's a
degree parameter K there's s which is a
subset of the field which is a set of
evaluation
points and then there's the message
which is viewed which is a K symbol
string which is viewed as a polinomial
of degree less than K from this field
and then you encode this
message by S capital S elements from the
field and the encoding is basically you
take the polinomial and write down the
evaluation of it at each single location
in at each of these evaluation points so
p is encoded as P of alpha 1 P of Alpha
2 p of alpha n short I'll represent it
this way and read M code is almost
exactly similar the only difference now
being
that this you're not you not in the
univariate setting you're in a higher
dimensional setting so the ambient
Dimension is some m m Two Three or a
larger Dimension you have a set of eval
points yes and you're looking at the
evaluation of the read M thing on a grid
on a grid of size s to the m the field
is much larger the field S field is much
s could be the fields the entire field
itself but we typically looking going to
look at the evaluation of this
multivariate polinomial on this grid of
side on this grid whose sides are all
denoted by this set of evaluation Point
s and it's exactly the same thing you
take a polinomial of degree at d a
multivariate polinomial and you're going
to spit out s to the m field symbols and
that's exactly this you're going to
write down the evaluation of the
polinomial P at each of the points in
this grid s to the
N yeah so if you're familiar with this
so quick notion let's know this let's
find out what's the distance of these
quotes we are very familiar with the
distance of the Cod so what goes into
analyzing the distance of the goodes for
re Solomon codes the we know that the
distance bounds count from the degree
Mantra basically it states that if you
have a non-zero polinomial of degree
strictly less than k then the number of
zeros of the polinomial is strictly less
than K that immediately translates to
the distance of the read Solomon
code for the read mer code there the
higher dimensional variant of the degree
Mantra which is more popularly called
the schwat zi Lama which says that if
you have a polinomial of a degree at
most d a non-zero polinomial then the
probability that it vanishes in a grid
is that a random point in the grid the
random point in the
grid the polinomial vanish ofand point
is at most D * the side length of the
git that's a SCH zip Lama the SCH zip
Lama immediately yields a distance bound
on the read merer code so these are two
codes which familiar with me talk about
one other code before we go on to before
I get on to the multiplicity code
definition it's this notion of folded
read Solomon
codes so folder read Solomon codes these
were introduced at least in the list
decoding context by guruswami and rudra
they were introduced in a slightly
different context earlier on but in the
list decoding context by guruswami and
rudra and these came with the it
primarily came for the motivation of
parvaresh B who noticed that even though
we knew that read Solomon codes were
list decodable up to the Johnson radius
and people want wanted to know it's be
codable beyond the Johnson radius Peres
noticed that if sort of if the
evaluation points were bunched up
together in some in a particular fashion
then you could beat the Johnson radius
and the folded R Solan code was
introduced as a a particular way of
bundling up bunching up the evaluation
points and what was the way of bundling
up the evaluation points so and we'll
have the usual read Solomon code setting
there's a field a degree parameter and a
set of evaluation points addition we'll
have some element gamma from the
multiplicator from fstar typically it's
a generator of the field but just
usually gamma is some element of higher
order
and you're going to take the read
Solomon code word which is just a bunch
of evaluations and you're now going to
bundle up certain evaluations for
example we going to bundle up
evaluations which all P of alpha 1 P of
gamma alpha 1 P of gamma s minus Alpha 1
we're going to bundle up them together
and give it as one symbol from the
larger alphabet F to the S instead we're
going to bundle up this the code
similarly this is for this is for
corresponding to the location alpha 1
similarly you have a location
corresponding to Alpha 2 and so on so we
it is the read Solomon code but in which
you're going to bundle up together and
this bundled up code rather that's why
it's called folded you fold these things
one over the other and you don't give a
the output alphabet is not a field
element but it is this F to the
S and the folder read Solomon code was
introduced and studied primarily for its
motivation
towards list decoding in particular
guruswami and rudra show the seminal
result that folder read Solomon codes
are list decodable all the way up to
capacity for certain choices of the
multiplicity parameter
yes yeah so what I'll do in the next
this one is I'm going to take a slightly
different Viewpoint what I will call the
ideal theoretic Viewpoint of the read
Solomon code the read M code as well as
the folded read Solomon code so the
classical the usual interpretation is
the message are the
polinomial either it's a univariate
polinomial in the case of read Solomon
or the multiv or multivariate polinomial
in the case of re meller and the
encoding is just the is just the set of
evaluation that's the evaluation of the
univariate polinomial and all the points
in the set of eval points or is the
evaluation of the multivariate
polinomial on all points in the grid
that's the usual represent Viewpoint
that we taken so the standard
representation which I talked about in
the previous slides what we'll do is
talk about a slightly alternate
Viewpoint in which each of these
elements I'm going to view them for
example let's take the read Solomon code
going to view P of alpha is also the
reminder that the polinomial P of X
leaves when you go mod the polinomial x
minus
Alpha it's the it's the it's the it's
the it's the mod of when you go mod this
ideal xus Alpha it's exactly P of alpha
is exactly that is the is the value that
you get when you rem divide the
polinomial P of alpha is exactly the
reminder when happens when you divide P
of X by xus
Alpha and that's that's the univariate
sort of representation in the
multivariate you can view P of alpha bar
as basically the I
as it's the polinomial P of X1 you go
mod this ideal it's an ideal generated
by the Pol the the linear polinomial xus
alpha 1 x- Alpha 2 x- Alpha M you take
out as many possible factors of these
whatever is left out is exactly the
evaluation of it and you can view it
this way this is a very strange way of
viewing Reed Solomon and readed Muller
but it'll come convenient to us in order
to introduce the multiplicity quotes any
questions on this I'm just rewriting our
natural representation of readed Solomon
and read M codes as ideal theoretic
codes I'm just writing them as mod an
ideal just a quick clarification
question can you hear me sure yes so
when you say the reader code you go mod
that ideal should that be X1 minus alpha
1 XM yeah yeah sorry yeah that should be
X1 minus alpha 1 yeah right thanks
M
thanks you go mod this
idea let's try to do this so this is
what that's the read Solomon sort of the
ideal view let's try to do the same
thing for folder read Solomon codes the
folder read Solomon codes what did we
see there was you're going to be going
to evaluate the polom we're going to
write the polinomial as a folded read
Solomon code word in particular we're
going to bundle up the points P Alpha P
gamma Alpha P GMA s minus one alpha all
together and give it as a symbol from a
large alphabet now if we take this sort
of Ideal theoretic Point View what we
are giving here is the polinomial P of X
Mod x - Alpha the polinomial P of X Mod
x - gamma Alpha and so on up to the
polinomial P of X Mod x - GMA s minus
one alpha we giving the polinomial mod
several uh several such
polinomial Now Chinese reminder theorem
says that if you want to give a
polinomial mod several things you might
as well give for the polinomial mod the
LCM of all of those and in this case
they happen to be co-prime therefore the
LCM will be the multiple of them so this
this is equivalent to just giving the
polinomial P of X Mod this larger
polinomial these two are exactly the
same representation if I have if I know
the polinomial P of X Mod this
polinomial that's the same as knowing P
of X Mod each of these Chinese remainder
theorem tells you that you can go back
and forth thereby is due to Chinese
remainder
theor I want to say this sort of tells
you
that tells a very General thing in which
you give a bunch
of polinomial and you can go mod that
polinomial so far we looked at
evaluation codes which were given a
polinomial give its evaluation at
several locations we could give take a
polinomial and give its mod several
polinomial more precisely what I say is
you can take this notion of an ideal
theoretic code which is sort of a
generalization of the notion of
evaluation codes that we have seen we're
familiar with so let E1 E2 n be
several n different polinomial all of
exact degree yes and to make it
convenient let's also actually assume
they are all monic
polinomial and you want to represent the
you want to represent the polinomial P
mod these ideals so what you'll do is
you'll just you'll give P mod each of
these
ideals that's a very natural extension
of it's a it's a larger framework in
which I can put read Solomon read m
folder R Solomon all of them under one
single umbrella that's so you give P mod
so you you encode a polinomial by giving
it mod several polinomial E1 to n the
question is which of these polinomial
what properties of these polinomial E1
to e n make this a good encoding so we
seen three examples so far read Solomon
read merer folded read Solomon each of
them have some very nice properties so
what I'd like to ask is what are are the
what are examples of polinomial E1 E2 n
such that this encoding is a nice input
is the question
clear
okay yeah and just this one so what's
happening over here is we are taking the
polinomial from this space which is
basically K elements from the field and
representing it using n elements n
polinomial each of degree at strictly
less than S so we are representing as n
elements from this large alphabet so
so the message which is K symbols is
being represented by n symbols but from
a slightly larger alphabet in this ideal
theoretic framework and couple of
remarks are in
order all I should mention here all this
is all univariate ideal theoretic
codes like read Solomon and folder read
Solomon are actually MDS codes they all
lie on the single turn bound single turn
bound and the entire framework that Mary
talked about in her first two lectures
in particular the unique decoding up to
half the the distance al bar Camp W
framework just extends almost
straightforward to this setting and the
almost exist the verb on the same
algorithm works
for all these ideal theoretic ques no
matter which which E1 E2 you choose and
it takes a little more work but you can
show that even the list decoding
algorithm all the way up to Johnson
radius Allah guruswami Sudan works that
is you can take exactly the algorithms
which may Mary talked about in the first
two lectures and these work for all the
this entire family of Ideal theoretic PS
they will you the bamp Welsh algorithm
works up to decoding up to Unique
decoding up to half the minimum distance
and the guruswami Sudan algorithm works
all the way up to Johnson radius for
this entire family of codes so
shouldn't I a question like sorry
question how can this work
for at least goe for this to
work you should not so so
you so the typical case the examples I
mentioned were all coprime if they are
not co-prime you just going mod their
LCM and it'll everything works out
yeah but let's assume for now that there
you can assume let's say that they are
all the examples we'll be dealing with
our co- Prime let's assume they are pair
wise co-
Prime I like to ask us what are E1 E2 en
which let you go beyond the Johnson
radius let you list decode beyond the
Johnson radius and we
note few examples and the most prominent
ones of them are the folder D Solon
codes we already saw what are the Eis in
that case the Eis are these product
polinomial and the multiplicity codes
are the ones in which the AIS are
exactly xus Alpha I to ^ s so this is
what is going to be the multiplicity
codes are ideal theoretic codes in which
you're going to go mod not x- Alpha I as
in read Solomon but xus Alpha I to the^
S I'm going to go mod this and write
this down at least for the case of
univariate for the multivariate we'll
have to do a little more work but that's
basically going to be the code so so let
me actually formally Define this code
let's formally Define univariate
multiplicity coures actually these were
defined well before all of this actually
even prior to the guruswami Sudan
algorithm by Rosen Bloom and sasman in
97 and subsequently neelsen analyzed the
guruswami Sudan algorithm for these un
multiplicity quotes in
2001 so what are univarate multiplicity
quotes we in the same setting as has in
read Solomon there's an underlying field
F there's a degree K and now there's an
extra parameter which is the
multiplic which is the
multiplicity parameter yes and we have a
set of evaluation points s for 1 to
alpha n the message space is the set of
degree at most K
polinomial and the code word space is
going to be this you're going to give
the polinomial mod f less than S in
particular we're going to give P exactly
this object we're going to give P of X
Mod xus Alpha to the^ s e for each one
for each of the alphas in
s let's take a closer look at what this
operation actually
does so so let's see what is p of X Mod
xus Alpha to the^ S so let's fix a
particular Alpha in
s it'll be convenient to think of alpha
to be zero but this works for all Alpha
we'll write P of P of X in the bases 1 x
- alpha x - Alpha squ and so on so you
can write P of X in the following
fashion I written the first s terms in
this basis and then the remaining the
higher order terms and what we really
care about is this part this is what is
going to be just this particular the
first one one particular symbol of the
multiplicity code is going to be P of X
it's going to be the first s terms of
this when I write P of X in this basis
it's going to be the first s terms of it
and should be familiar this almost looks
like the tailor series The Tailor series
typically has
some numbers sitting here it typically
has I factorial sitting here this is the
so these and in which case the pi Alphas
will be the derivatives but these are we
don't have those denominators sitting
there so these are not derivatives but
something very closely related and Hass
derivatives that's actually more
convenient to work with HD derivatives
because if you working with finite
Fields it's unclear if you can do some
divisions so some divisions might be
forbidden so it's actually cleaner to
work with HD derivatives than regular
derivatives so the pi Alphas are has
derivatives they are almost they share
more or less all the properties as the
derivatives except for some scalings and
the first s has derivatives are what
constitutes the S field elements that
you're going to give in order to
represent a polinomial at a particular
location this is the definition of the M
unate multiplicity code you're going to
give P mod xus Alpha so for every loc
for every Alpha you're going to give
p p the evaluation of that point the
first derivative and all the way up to
the S minus first derivative and so on
for each of the alphas in the field in
the evaluation
s okay and I'm going to use this
representation short this is p less than
alpha s is this combined is this entire
thing put together I'm going to call it
P less than S of alpha so this is an
element
from F to the
S
questions okay and this also will let us
sort of this sort of we of writing it
will also let us move to the multi
version of these codes and sort of it's
cleaner because for f FRS codes I don't
know what's the natural multivariate
version of it whereas once you take the
ideal the framework it's very clean to
talk about what's the multivariate
version of the multiplicity codes and
this multivariate version was introduced
by karti saraf and yakan in
2011 and it's almost exactly the same
setup as before the only thing that's
different we have now have just like
it's just going to be what multivariate
multiplicity codes or to univariate
multiplicity codes what read M codes are
to read solivan codes it's just you're
working going to work with a larger
Dimension so the only difference out
here is this you have a larger Dimension
M and what we're going to to do is we're
going to give this polinomial
P degree at most D polinomial in the
variable we going to give it mod May
mentioned I think this there's a typo
here I'm going to give mod the idea X X1
- alpha 1 X2 - Alpha 2 XM minus
Al I'm going to give it mod this
idea and the most natural thing
equivalently you can either think of it
as giving it a representative mod this
ideal or you can actually go ahead and
write down P of X in the appropriate
basis if you write it in the appropriate
basis that is all possible combinations
of the form x i minus Alpha I and then
collect all the first collect all the
terms for which the exponent Vector is
of size
at the exponent Vector is of size at
most of weight at most s that will be P
of X Mod x - one X1 - Alpha 1 X2 - Alpha
2 XM - Alpha M to the^ S these are the
higher order terms which you're going to
drop out so this will be one single
symbol of this is the symbol
corresponding to a particular Alpha bar
we'll do this for every Alpha bar in in
the grid s to the m that's how the
multivariate multiplistic quot is
present you give you give this
large symbol basically this is going to
be a polinomial mentioned over here this
is going to be
a polinomial from the space so every
so the AL the code the output space the
alphabet is going to be this is going to
be the alphabet of the output
space
okay so that's so much for the
definition of univariate multiplicity
codes and multivariate multiplicity
codes
let's ask what's the distance rate and
distance of these quotes why do we work
with these quotes is and hopefully they
have good rate and good distance is
there a
question yeah so univ multiplicity codes
the rate is clear from this one you're
taking
k k field symbols and outputting small s
symbols of this one so the rate this
should be clear it should be evident
that this is the rate of the code what
about distance so let's go back to how
we found analyze distance for read
Solomon codes we use the degree mantra
for it and what you need the degree
Mantra just says the number of zeros of
a nonzero degree less than K polinomial
is strictly less than K this is actually
true even if you count
multiplicities so once you take the
stronger version this will immediately
give you the distance of the univariate
multiplicity code it gives you that the
distance is 1 minus K of s * modus and
hence this is also an m s said MDS codes
in fact all univariate ideal uh
univariate ideal theoretic codes are MDS
and and so is the univariate
multiplicity
code stents so this should be clear what
about the distance of the multivariate
multiplicity we talking about this code
in which you're taking a polinomial a
degree D polinomial and you're
representing it
mod this
idea okay notice s equals 1 case is
exactly the read M case and there we had
you argued distance using the schwat zip
LMA the schwat zip LMA is came is what
came handy to talk about the distance of
the read M code so now if we want to
argue about the distance of the
multivariate multiplicity code we will
need a multiplicity variant of the
schwart zle Lama the it's just not going
to talk about how frequently is the
polinomial zero but what with what
multiplicity does it is it zero we want
to count this so let's so actually so
we're going to talk about What's called
the multiplicity schwartzle LMA
schwartzle Lama which incorporates into
it the multiplicity
feature and this actually was first the
multiplicity short was first proven by
karti SAR and San and let's just State
what it is it's the natural
generalization of the classical SCH
zipple Lemma to the multiplicity
setting what is it for this firstly
we'll have to extend the notion of
Multiplicity so for multiplicity for
univariate polinomial is very clear just
the number of times the polinomial
becomes zero it's the number of
derivatives which are all zero we want
to extend this notion to higher
Dimensions we'll do it the natural way
it's if it's if you're working over the
reals it's easy it's sort of in to how
you define this it's this one but you're
working on finite Fields so we're going
to Define it in the following fashion so
let P be an P be some
polinomial and a be some point in the
space and I want to Define what is the
multiplicity of the polinomial P at the
point a so you're going to look at all
the derivatives of it all the Hass
derivatives of this polinomial the has
derivatives of order zero which is the
evaluation the first order has
derivatives the second order has
derivatives and so on you're go and keep
looking at it and it's the largest M
such that for all exponent vectors all H
derivatives whose order is less than M
the corresponding has derivative is zero
so you want it's the largest M for which
this is true for the zero polinomial the
is m is infinity in which case you
define m p of a to be Infinity for
everything else they will this will be a
fixed number it's the largest M such
that all derivatives all Hass
derivatives of order below M are all
vanish at this point a then this is the
multiplicity of this and the one and so
now given this we can write down the
extension of the SCH zipo the classical
this is the classical short Z basically
I just Rewritten it this it's it says
the expected time
that given a non-zero polinomial the
expected number of locations in which p
is zero is less than D
modus in the grid the multiplicity zip
just says I'm going to replace this
indicator random variable whether a
polinomial is zero or Not by the
multiplicity and still the inequality
holds good so it's a strengthening of
the classical short
suppl so this is this is always the than
equal to this this is just talking about
the first order has a derivative this is
talking about as many has it says even
if you take this expectation with
multiplicity in account that's at most D
time D over
modus it then you pick a random point in
the grid s to the end this immediately
gives
us
the distance of the multivariate
multiplicity polinomial in particular it
says if you take two different
polinomial p and Q which are distinct
what we asking what's what's the
distance of a code you're asking how
many times rather one minus the distance
is how many times is are the hasd
derivatives at a point a and at at a
random Point equal for the two distinct
polins this is exactly the probability
that the multiplicity of the polinomial
P minus Q at the point a is at least s
and Marco will tell you that this is at
most d by SS and hence we have that an
immediate corollary of this is the fact
the distance
of code is at least 1 minus D /
s you gain this Factor s over the usual
read M code question so
far
okay so what we will do see we'll see
two about about the 30 more minutes what
I'll see and do in the remaining 30
minutes you'll see two applications of
these codes one for the univariate
setting and other for the multivariate
setting and this univ setting will be
very similar to Mary's lecture on list
decoding codes we
ask so one of the reasons one of the big
reasons multiplicity univarate
multiplicity codes were studied in
coding theory is because they are list
decodable well beyond the Johnson radius
in fact they are list decodable for
certain choices of the multiplicity
parameter all the way to
capacity more precisely
kopari and guruswami Van
independently showed that show
considered the following problem that is
you basically given the list decoding
problem is the following problem you're
given a reced word which is basically
you're
given for each of the N evaluation
points you are given
this symbol from this large alphabet
beta I less than S which is given this
symbol and you want to find all degree
de polom P such that which have good
agreement with the given reced basically
you want to find this have agreement at
least T that's this one if this was The
Distance by two this a unique decoding
and we want to find as large a as
smaller t as possible and if T we can
make it all the way up to 1 minus
r that's says it goes up to capacity so
that's the question we want to look at
right now this is a list decoding
question we want to analyze stud
univarate multiplicity codes from the
view point of list decoding is the
problem clear and then I'll get on to
the sort of solution the algorithm which
we have which will be very similar to
which will be identical to the sort of
linear algebric framework that Mary
discussed in ester's
lectures
okay and so karti and guruswami
independently they give slightly
different algorithms but ESS Al they
show exact the following they showed
that for every rate R and Epsilon there
is a multiplicity parameter s there's a
lar of s such that the univariate
multiplicity code with degree d block
length n multiplicity s and rate this
one over fields of characteristic at
least D * n is list decodable from so
many fraction of errors this basically
says this is basically says
that list code univarate multiplicity
code
of larg in of
Multiplicity or L deportable to
capacity okay and before I sort of try
to give a high level idea of how this
statement is proven I want to just to
stare at this theorem statement say that
it doesn't by the way it doesn't show
that all univariate multiplicity codes
are less decodable up to capacity it
only says if you want to come Epsilon
close to capacity then you need the
multiplicity parameter to be suitably
large enough so it says if you depending
on how close you want to come to
capacity it gives you a particular
family of univarate Multiplicity codes
which are less decod all the way up to
capacity that's one it doesn't show all
univariate multiplicity codes are list
decodable up to capacity two and the
bigger issue is this is the current
proof has the caveat that it works only
if the underlying characteristic is
large enough the definition of univarate
multiplicity codes did not care about
characteristic but at least both the
algorithm both the karti algorithm as
well as the guruswami Wang algorithm
both require the analysis sort of breaks
down if the underly the characteristic
of the underlying field happens to be
small it needs the characteristic to be
large enough for the proof to go through
so this is a caveat of this we don't
know so this is actually an open
question out here what happens to
univariate multiplicity codes when the
characteristic is small and does and
what also what happens to other
multiplicity parameters smaller
multiplicity parameters do we know how
to list decode them beyond the Johnson
radius for these settings we don't know
the answer to this question okay so
that's the statement of the theorem as
we know so any questions before I move
to give a sort of a high level view of
how this theorem is
gr I have a question if I want to reduce
field size do people ever consider
subfield subcodes of these to like
because you're blowing up the field side
size by S to try and get it back down so
you're not the field you're talking
about the alphabet size yeah
yeah so no so what was your suggestion
what was your this one whether people
have considered subfield sub codes like
when you go from bch readall codes to
bch codes you can also
take so usually what's done okay so that
you could ask for this I haven't seen s
sort of that's interesting I haven't
seen such sort of work us what's done to
get back to Cod this one say Conant alha
is you do concatenation and reduce the
alphabet size and analyze how concat how
list how the list decoding algorithms
work under
concatenation I haven't seen the bch
version in this
context and ALS I haven't seen it it' be
interesting to see such
things
okay proceeding to the algorithm okay so
and the algorithm is going to be we're
going to follow there by the way there
are two different algorithms for this
right now very similar but two different
algorithms one is the algorithm D swti
partti and the other is to wut guruswami
and Carol wank
and as Mary did in her talk we will
follow the linear algebraic framework of
guruswami and Wang while describing the
solution there's an alternate
solution due to swastic it has certain
advantages over this it's more
complicated but has certain advantages
we will not get into this um I might try
to answer that address that later on
either in the open questions or later on
the differences between the guruswami
Wang algorithm and the swastic karti and
copar
algorithm so how does these algorithm
how do these things work so it's like
the ble Camp Welch algorithm or the
guruswami Sudan algorithm the first step
is somehow find an algebraic explanation
for the entire Reed word somehow we find
an algebraic representation what is this
algebraic explanation we basically find
some polinomial in this case it's some M
M plus M plus one variate polinomial we
introducing new variables y0 y1 Y2 ym
minus one this m is some number between
Z and S minus and s s is the
multiplicity parameter remember it's
some number between these two and Q is
some polinomial of this
type it's a polinomial which say ax plus
summation i = 0 y i * F The crucial
thing to notice is the degree in y in
each of the yis is one the degrees in a
could be large there are some degree
constraints on A's and the bis I'm I'm
going to skip that for now it'll be
evident in the next few slides what are
the degree constraints I need to put in
we going to find some polinomial that
satisfies a bunch of conditions all will
be linear conditions in the coefficients
of A and B A and the b i what inste of
explicitly instead of describing what
the conditions star are what I'll tell
you is what do we need from the these
conditions and then it should be evident
what these what these conditions star
star star are going to be so what do we
want from this we want the following
thing we want that the conditions to be
such that if suppose there's some
polinomial p and the received word
suppose they happen to agree at a
particular Point say at the point Alpha
so the polinomial p p l and beta less
they happen to agree at this point the
conditions that we impose should be such
that if you look at the polinomial r ofx
which is take this polinomial Q which I
defined over
here and plug into
it instead of the y i p of X the first
derivative of P of X the first has a
derivative the second has a derivative
all the way up to the m minus one has a
derivative if you look at this
polinomial which I defined this
way this polinomial should have a root
at at the point Alpha I with
multiplicity s minus M the the
conditions basically are just to make
sure that this is the
case these are a bunch of linear
constraints each constraint telling you
the this order derivative is zero this
order derivative is zero and the
condition star star star exactly these
conditions to ensure that if these two
happen
then this polom rfx has a root at Alpha
a with multiplicity s minus M and why is
such
a condition
useful now suppose P was a polinomial
such that P and the Reed
word agreed not just at this point Alpha
I but at T such
points that would mean that this
polinomial r ofx that we have defined
this way has s minus m s- m * T Roots
that's counting with multiplicity for
each of the T points of agreement it
gets in a zero with multiplicity s- M so
therefore the polinomial r ofx as s- M *
T Roots counting with multip ities and
in particular if we had set the degree
parameters for a and bi such that the
degree of this
polinomial the degree of this polinomial
happens to be less than S minus M * T we
get that R is identically
zero so the degree parameters are set
such that when you plug in P P1 P2 PM
minus 1 into
Q these are notice these are at most
degree this a degree K po is a kus1
polinomial kus2 all the way up to k- M
minus1 if you plug in this then the
resultant polinomial has to be of degree
at most s minus Mt we set it up so that
this is the case then R is identically
zero in other words for every Point
polinomial P that has significant
agreement with the received word we will
have that this
polinomial when you PL when you
plug when you plug in P of X P1 of X
into Q This Will P will be a solution to
this we get a differential equation of
which P will be a root of in particular
so we're going to have the following we
find an algebric explanation so the for
R in particular we'll find a polinomial
QX y not ym of this form satisfying
these conditions and these conditions
are exactly the conditions that are
required to make this happen you can
check this these are just linear
conditions these are just linear
conditions it's a bunch of linear
conditions we write just one after
another we write all of them down and
that's step one we just going to find a
polinomial q with certain linear
constraints satisfying this there's a
bunch of homogeneous linear constraints
if the number of variables is more than
the number of constraints then there is
a solution so you pick just picked one
sub Solution that's how it goes that's
how this proceeds I'm not writing
explicitly what star star star is in
fact it's not very insightful knowing
what it is all that you know is the star
star the condition star star star are
the conditions that
make this make this observation go
through whatever makes this observ just
write that down and that's what this one
is now once we have this we have from
the previous step that every root every
closing of polinomial is a solution of
this differential equation so step two
should just be we now have to solve the
differential equation we have the
polinomial Q we have to find all
polinomial P for which this is
identically
zero we have to solve this differential
equation this is different from what
Mary had suggested in Mary's this one it
they were not differential equations
they were just Q of X comma P of X there
was just factors of the form you had to
find factors here we have differential
equations that we need to solve but this
but the way to solve them is exactly the
same you just similar to factorization
you first write this equation mod x find
the constant term go mod x square go
each of them write it down WR write down
what should P be and you notice that the
solution is just you'll get a bunch of
linear equations and you have to solve
the system in fact if you write it
carefully it'll be an upper triangular
system and it'll be extremely easy to
solve it the solving the differential
equation is not a hard task at all you
just write down what this condition
means if you write it on this one it
will be an upper triangular system in
the coefficients of p with just m or
degrees of freedom and that those so
once you fix the first lower lower or
small coefficients for p you can
complete the upper triangle system will
tell you now there's a natural way to
satisfy the differential equation you
solve it and that's it so step one and
step two are this so step one finds an
algebraic explanation for the entire
received word step two and because with
the way it's step one has been done it
ensures that every polinomial which is
close enough to this satisfies a
particular differential equation and
then you solve this differential
equation that's step two and both are in
the in the guruswami Wang approach they
are ex they are linear both linear
algebraic solution this is solving a
homogeneous system of linear equations
this is not a homogeneous system but if
you write it down carefully this will
just be an upper triangular system and
it's very easy to solve
this
Okay C any questions on this otherwise
I'll say a couple of remarks and what's
happened since the algorithm of
guruswami and
Bank the first thing to notice is what I
said now is a a fully deterministic
algorithm it's it's a bunch of goian
solving various gion systems that list
decodes the capacity and will output
list of size Q to the m and why is it Q
to the m it's you just notice that
there's an upper triangular system in
which there are M degrees of freedom
therefore once you fix the M degrees of
freedom for this it's not evident from
here what's m degrees of freedom but you
can check that it has M degrees of
freedom at most M degrees of
freedom once you fix that the all the
the entire polinomial p is fixed
therefore the atmost Q to the m
polinomial so this algorithm which I
suggested in the previous slide actually
gives
you a deterministic algorithm that list
decodes a capacity and outputs lists of
size possibly as large as Q to the m you
can further of course prune these things
you can throw away pols which are not
close enough but it'll give you list of
size at most as large as qdm and this is
an efficient
algorithm subsequent to this actually in
very recent work five years ago kopti
Roni saraf and voters observed that the
list size actually can be reduced
considerably from Q to the m which seems
to be a pol polom large function they
show that you can actually reduce it to
a constant the constant some depending
on how close you are to capacity order
Epsilon one this is a randomized
procedure they just showed that
basically if it was using the
observation
that here this algorithm output
polinomial which are all solutions
sitting in an ained space and they
showed that a cord with good distance
cannot have a lot of code words in an
aine space it has to they can't have PM
code wordss it will actually be much
much smaller and they gave a randomized
pruning algorithm to reduce the list
size from qm to order Epsilon one to a
constant size
list and this it's a randomized
procedure to do this it' be interesting
to actually get a deterministic
counterpart to the the pruning algorithm
of kopar Roni
Saras more recently earlier this year in
joint work with goel Kumar and Shanker
we showed that actually this algorithm
which was solving various Gan systems
and seem to be
actually polom it us runs in times at
least n Cube can actually be made to run
in quasilinear time it can be made to
run in order n polog in time that is you
can carefully look at step one and step
two and notice that actually the systems
that they solve are very nicely well
behaved systems and you can reduce the
running time from poly in N to n poly
log n in running time by the way this
all of this all of this which I said
right now this set of framework works
for the folder read Solomon code word
both the the pruning algorithm as well
as the nearly linear time works for the
folder read
Sol any questions
on that's sort of what I wanted to say
about univ multiplicity codes and their
list and their list decodability all the
way up to capacity I haven't gone
through the parameters but you just you
once you have this algorithm you write
it down and you can show that there is a
particular choice of S and M for which
the corresponding univarate multiplicity
code will go all the way up to
capacity okay so another 10 minutes what
I will talk about is other very nice
application of of multi of multiplus
decodes this time the multivariate
counterpart there a local decoding of
multiv VAR multiplicity codes is there a
question
or yeah in
particular and this is sort of read M
codes are known to be are known to be
local decoding locally decodable in
particular if you want
to locally decode a read merer code you
given a noisy read merer code code word
how do you locally decode it you at a
particular Point location you pass
several lines through it take the
majority voting and hope that this would
work and many a time this this works and
we would like to ask is a similar thing
true for multivariate multiplicity codes
why do we care for doing this and in
fact this was the original motiv
motivation of karti saraf and yakan when
they defined multivariate multiplicity
codes they defined multivariate multi
Cod precisely for this reason for their
application to local
dequ because the read M code which I
just mentioned has it's locally
decodable but locally decodable with sub
sublinear query complexity but on the
other hand the rate is never more than a
half for reader codes reader codes rate
stops at half so you never get high rate
codes which are locally decodable and it
was open for a long time whether there
exist codes which have rate better than
half in fact rates all the way close to
one which are also locally decodable
with sublinear query
complexity and karti saraf and yakan
actually introduced discovered
multivariate multiplicity codes
precisely for this reason they showed
that for every Epsilon and
Alpha Epsilon is how sublinear you want
to be Alpha is the rate of the code how
close you want it to be one and every
any Dimension K there are multiplicity
codes of Dimension K rate 1 minus Alpha
and locally decodable from constant
fraction of errors in sublinear amount
of
time so the improvement over read merer
comes in the fact that they can handle
rate going arbiterly close to one you
tell me how close you you want to and I
will give you how close you want the
rate to be to one and how sublinear you
want it to be in the this one and I will
give you a
code and I will give you a multiplicity
multivariate multiplicity code which is
locally decodable in that sublinear time
and with rate 1 minus
Al okay this was the original motivation
of karti s yakan when they introduce
multivariate multiplicity codes
subsequent to their work of course there
have been several alternate
constructions which also satisfy this
which also yield the same sort of
construction they are different codes
these are not multivariate multiplicity
codes in particular go karti and Sudan
and go showed that there are certain
family of aine invariant codes which
have this property hemway ostroski and
Mary showed that there are certain codes
based on expander codes which can also
have which are locally decodable High
rate
locally good but what we will see what
I'll show give you is it will give you a
very high level birs picture of why
multivariate multiplicity codes do
achieve do you're able to locally decode
from them was there a
question yeah maybe just to clarify so
you know taking Epsilon really really
small you know if I make it say sub like
sub constant I guess the the ter your
constant you're hiding in the O big go
will blow up yeah yeah so the constants
I'm hiding here
will it will basically this like to the
to like one over log n or something I
don't yeah I don't think I don't think
they can make this poly poly log K this
algorithm gets you can make Epsilon to
be slightly subc constant but I don't
think you can make this sub this subc
constant to go all the way small to
polylog K from where the parameters look
but I'm not you can't make it polylog K
that I'm definitely wish sure of it but
you can certainly make Epsilon to be
something slightly sub subc
constant it can goes it can be a little
low one
number
yeah
okay okay so once again what's the
problem here so we are given some word
we given some f on the entire
space basically for every point in the
space f to the m we're now looking at
multivar multiplicity codes which are
defined on a grid and we going to assume
the grid is the
entire F to the m now we are given
basically for the entire F to the m we
are given for each location we are given
a polinomial of degree atmost s over
there and we are told that this function
is actually close to some encoding of an
honest to God multivariate multiplicity
code in other words there is some
polinomial P of degree atmost D such
that if you pick a
random such that F and P disagree on a
random location at most Delta not
probability and Delta not say is less
than
Delta by 8 where Delta is the distance
of the
poe and you're then given a point Alpha
in the whole space and you want to
find what you want to find is actually
the value of the closest code word at
the location Alpha that's what you want
to find pictorially what you have is
this that is you given you given this
table of values for every point in this
Grid in this space you're given a
polinomial and there's a bunch of
locations say this uh Violet shaded area
where it's erroneous but you don't know
this region that's erroneous you're
given you're given F here you promise
that it's f is very close to some P you
do not know where the errors happen and
then you're given a point Alpha say this
point Alpha it's possible Poss you don't
not know if it's an erroneous point or a
non- erroneous point and you want to
find the closest code word at the
location
Alpha that's a picture we have so we
have F like this there's error there's
an error set over
here error set is promised to be not too
large but we don't know where the error
set is and you need to find out and
you're given an alpha which could be in
the error set or elsewhere and you need
to find out P
of
you want to find the closest Cod word at
the location
of how many I have about five more
minutes maybe or yeah something like
that yeah okay let me so quickly tell
what's going to happen here so the the
algorithm designed by kopar and sarakan
for this with further modification
actually what I'm going to give this the
algorithm due to swastic kopar and a
subsequent modification of the KY
algorithm is as
follows so the natural thing to it's
going to be very much motivated by the
read meller thing we going to shoot off
lines through this point Alpha look at
the Restriction of the multivariate
multiplicity code to these lines you're
going to get univariate multiplicity
codes you're going to decode them and
then put those information together to
be actually able to decode at the point
Alpha now how do we choose we need to
figure out which are the we want to
choose a large set of nice set of lines
so the way the case sorry
so the way the set of lines is chosen in
the following fashion let s be some
large set of this ones which is of size
10 s Square notice s is the multiplicity
parameter so this is just a large
constant s we think of it as a constant
you go to some high order multiplicity
it's a constant so it's just some large
subset size of the field the field could
be growing in N but this is just a
constant size subset of the thing you
pick randomly a B1 B2
BM the things in the field in the s
space f to the m and you pick this
collection of points B which is
basically a plus summation ribi for r i
is being in s notice that for a typical
choice for a typical choice of
B for a typical the size of B will be S
to the
N if there are no linear dependencies
and so if you're lucky this one they
won't
what
happened I don't know why my screen stop
sharing just give me a
second you choose the set of points
B and what we will do is for each beta
in B for each beta in B we'll shoot a
line in the in the direction beta
through Alpha we're going to shoot this
line this way we're going to shoot this
line beta through this and we'll obtain
the Restriction we'll query the so we're
going to query it on several suchar
lines we're going to query the code word
on several such lines and you're going
to get you you can you'll get the
Restriction of the multivariate
multiplicity received word on this line
This most likely because these lines are
chosen at Rand most there going to be
very few errors and you can on for a
good fraction of the lines you will
actually be able to decode the Univar
the corresponding univariate
multiplicity code fully Faithfully
you'll be able to do the list decoding
assuming you can do decoding of
univarate Multiplicity codes so in
particular you'll get this polinomial Q
beta e t which is a polinomial in just
this
direction now so for most for for most a
for most choices of a randomness at
least 2/3 of the lines that you shoot in
you'll have that this polinomial Q beta
e t is actually the corresponding haet
derivative of this you'll you'll be this
is just forget about notation you'll
actually be honestly be able to get the
univariate multiplicity code along that
direction now from this I want to
recover what is PE at Alpha notice it we
only have PE at Alpha plus bet
T and you do not know where which of the
points are correct which of which lines
are correct which line you know the 2/3
of the lines are corrected stuff so what
we'll do is we look at
the just look at this
polinomial look at this polinomial just
look at the coefficient of T J in the
above polinomial you get a polinomial in
the variables
beta you get the coefficient of this is
going to be something in the variables
beta and beta beta choices and if you
notice it the polinomial that you get
will actually be a degree s polinomial
it's m variate
and it's a it's exactly a multiplicity
encoding on the set B the set B which we
have defined over
here which looks like a grid s the^
m so this is a smaller set problem of
the same type but on a much smaller the
degrees is of size yes it's a small it's
a constant degree polinomial it's it's
the same problem but a constant degree
and you have the entire information here
you can do sort of a global decoding for
this and recover P Al I'm hand waving a
lot but this is essentially the entire
algorithm of kartis kares improvement
over K ksy is exactly this you shoot
several lines you infer the univariate
multiplicity code on these lines and
then you look at them you want to put
these information together you realize
that what you have is actually a
constant degree M variate multiplicity
encoding on the set B and that you can
do some Global decoding to recover it
and that's the entire algorithm of it
then you set the parameters correctly
you get
the theorem I
stated okay what I will do in the
remaining in the next few minutes is
just wrap up with a few open questions
multi codes I really love this set of
family of codes been lot of nice
questions let me start off with
questions related to
decoding the first questions related to
decoding are related to actually the
questions I talked about what exactly
just like read Solomon code what is the
list decoding radius of Multiplicity
codes we know that they can all be list
decoded up to the Johnson radius for
certain choices of the multiplicity
parameter it goes all the way up to
capacity but only if the characteristic
is large enough what happens to the
other multiplicity parameters and for
other characteristic this is open but
this possibly is intimately tied with
what happens in the case of read Solomon
Cod wordss that's for univariate for
multivariate in fact we could ask can we
even do unique decoding algorithmically
there have been partial results which
sort of answer this
uh recently due to building on work due
to Kim and karti and also whether you
can do list decoding all of these
results are not completely satisfactory
they only show it for certain choices of
s we can do unique decoding all the way
up to half the minimum distance we can
do list decoding on grids but they don't
answer this question completely it's so
it's widely open how to do for
multivariate do unique decoding up to
how even unique decoding we don't have
an algorithmic thing for all parameters
of s and list decoding i' would like to
ask up to John radius do we have we
don't yet know how to do this for the
multivariate
setting next question which you can ask
is given such a code are these we show
they were locally decodable are they
locally testable like read M codes are
they locally read M codes have been
should be locally testable and this is
been used for pcps it would be
interesting if multivariate multiplicity
codes are also testable then they
possibly have some PCP
applications theyve been once again we
this is a very it's not an area that's
been well explored we don't have any
results they've been recent results due
to carliner Salama tashma and Carin and
tashma who show that the line tester is
not a good test for multivariate
multiplicity code but possibly the plane
tester is but this doesn't yet still
answer the question completely it
doesn't answer the question as well as
we know for read meller codes could then
ask are there other applications readed
Muller and readed Solomon have zillion
applications in coding Theory and other
elsewhere in theoretical computer
science do multivariate multiplicity and
univariate multiplicity quotes have
applications recently once again tashma
unnown has been working on this
multiplicity ques quite a lot in the
last couple of years in joint work with
Kev he shows that you can sort of build
unbalanced expanders and in particular
recover the result of guruswami umans
and
vadan from multiplicity quotes from
univariate multiplicity codes it be
interesting to get more
results yeah
I know I'll conclude with this thanks we
should remark that most of my talk was
based on this survey article by swastik
from 2014 except for the results that
came subsequently to it it's a very nice
article by swastic some remarks on
multiplicity codes I'll stop with
this did we have time for one quick
question um just uh thanks for theight
talk um out of curiosity can you adjust
the local decoding algorithm get a local
list decoding algorithm instead of just
local decoding along lines you just run
like
G yes you can yes you
can yeah it's and this is it's yeah you
can do it you can do exactly what you
did for id M codes in this context also
I don't know I don't recall at the top
of my mind how well are the parameters
but you can do what what one does for
read M or even for multivariate
multiplicity
codes actually one more question as
well okay thanks I also have one other
kind of silly question maybe but I'm
curious so um the way you you said that
you know you can go from univariate
multiplicity codes to multivariate
multiplicity codes just by picking
appropriate ideals could you do the same
has anyone tried doing the same game
with like a full de Sol codes I guess
you would have to then just have M
different variables and then you would
have like you would take the ideal xus
gamma to the J Alpha I for J going from
Z to S minus one and I running from one
to M um has that been looked at at all
or is that even so there have been Works
which looked at this they have been
works but I none of them Seem doesn't I
haven't so they've been work more from
in the arithmetic complexity Theory
where they've been trying to design
pseudo random generators and stuff this
context they have come considered for
multivariate versions of folded R rate
Solomon codes but somehow they have the
results are not as clean as one gets
from multivariate multiplicity codes and
it's properly because the choice of
Ideal is not the right one or we don't
yet understand it or this one but this
has not been explored well enough for
your the mul I don't know what is the
right analog of multivariate analog of f
FRS
codes and what do they give you also
let's thank pad again for the great
[Applause]
talk and as us